so hey I'm shy I'm an independent data
size consultant if you need help with
data science I don't have time for you
I'm very busy
but maybe I'll help you in my free time
I like helping with cool stuff if I can
there's a sticker data hack here if you
don't know our hackathon data science
hackathon please find us on Facebook
Meetup
we have a cool new projects planned for
2020 besides our yearly hackathon and
our meetup group which is an enemy of
Pilate at Tel Aviv you're my enemy I'm
gonna I'm kidding but real good friends
we give lectures of each other's meetups
but I also have a chance once in a while
to go into different topics because of
my consulting in one of the topics I I
got into recently the last year or so is
cause I'd burn some time series data and
I did I had like a research period but I
did a very thorough literature review of
the topic and really got to know it and
it turned out to be really I thought
well how do you know if one time serious
causes another maybe just like maybe use
I don't know she learning or if you
don't have level what do you do probably
have some statistical tools there to be
a huge topic started off with really
kind of the inceptions of the
econometrics and it has been really
innovated in in the last two decades
from various fields so turned to be
quite a big research cycle and I I wrote
this down in a blog post which is super
long and it's not really a valid blog
post but you can this is like a 14
minutes version of it oh this is work
working and so we'll start off with the
motivation why what's the what causal
inference is about why is it interesting
so I think the the basic question causal
inference tries to answer is does X cos
Y and this is a very interesting
question right we can think about a lot
of real
life examples where we ask these
questions and they make us money they
say it saves life it explains something
in nature so here's an example set of
examples this drug excuse condition why
the smoking cause cancer
how can I you know what what drives what
in economics is a lot of these types of
questions like daily stock prices drives
creating volumes or vice versa or both
or or some value of a currency how sea
temperatures affect volume fishing
etcetera etcetera etcetera in every
field you can think about in every
domain this kind of questions pop up
naturally both as part of scientific
investigation and as part of doing
business and billing products so the
first two questions can usually be
framed as questions on distributions or
a very discrete event and they it's kind
of the other the other half of causal
inference but the two last ones are
questions on time series data we're
looking at a later cause of arrivals
like some kind of signal coming and
progressing or changing over time or two
signals of rival few hundreds or
thousands or more and we're asking which
one of them cracks which or several them
driving several of them and how and this
turned so I think the basic intuition of
a lot of people is maybe I'll train a
model to predict one from the other or
one from many others and I look at just
what the model uses to predict and it
turns out this is a good direction but
it's not enough so predictability is not
causality signals can be very
predictable the matter sync signal
without being the cause of it and this
whole field deals exactly what that like
will see the issue of predictability
that does come up in a very basic
intuition of what what causal inference
how it can be fine but it it is it is a
bit more nuanced than just
predictability so so this is again de
right a motivation and I added this this
is a car Pearson has quoted saying
statistics is a grammar of science so I
want to add if if statistics is the
grammar of science then surely call them
for instance semantics in the sense that
it tells it governs how we attribute
meaning to scientific tools or side
effect phrases so what's the agenda for
tonight we'll start with like a brief
overview basically not notions of
causality as you said about one notion
and then I'll mention a few more very
briefly so we just go over the bait the
first and most important one just to
understand how it is defined
statistically and then we'll just go
over a list of methods and we'll do it
it will be kind of time based in the
sense that we'll start from the
classical ones will maybe have a few
problems with them we'll see why did why
we had to innovate innovate and adapt
them and use method for model fields to
start to look at causal inference and
then we'll go over the more the newer
coil
we're the ones from conceit CAF theory
information theory graph theory and
we'll finally go over a few ground rules
a few heuristics I came up with try to
making sense of how to choose which
approach to use and I have to say that
maybe you shouldn't listen to me because
I only use Coughlin's prints in like on
tons of data on a couple of projects and
these are rules that are basically I try
to infer from the understanding of the
basic properties of each method what
it's good at what it's bad at what's the
input X plis it and implicit assumptions
it makes on the data the system you're
looking at and by combining these I try
to come up with could you listicles and
if you have comments or things to
all right you won't tell me I'm wrong
then please do so it will be a semi
technical talk because we're trying to
go over a lot of things so it's not
going to be a lot of mathematics or
something or hardly any of it because
we're trying to touch upon a lot of
different fields and honestly in many of
them I don't have the mathematical
background I can quell chaos theory to
really understand everything that goes
inside each and every method so I really
try to take to understand the heart of
the method the claims that it makes how
it does what it does and and so and even
if I did I wouldn't have the time I
prefer to give you a tool box for you to
use when you want to approach a causal
inference problem and hang some rich
data and have you on have you give you a
point to start from when you choose a
tool understand how you choose it and
what you can apply and I wouldn't be
able to give you advice on some of the
tools here because I haven't used them
and haven't given us so that's uh I
think you can find a blog post pretty
easily maybe I'll put a comment on the
Meetup
you can find it on my website which is
there's a URL the start and the end of
the presentation it's my name com
so it is defined and it's super long so
if you ever do need a more technical in
the thing you can start from there and
it has all the references and links and
I try to want to go a little more deep
in the post but first I want to do a
very quick recap of stochastic processes
because it's we're gonna they're gonna
come up again and again and just want to
make sure we all know what a stochastic
process and versus a time series so
we're gonna talk about real stochastic
processes and this is the definition is
very simple and this is a mathematical
definition of what a stochastic
processes which is the thing that we say
that generates time to data it's the
mathematical object that meant to
represent
the thing that generates the values we
see in our time series data the process
in reality innocence and it's just a
family of real random variables they're
indexed by Sammy Cole the index set okay
they all define the same probability
space if you don't know probability it's
not gonna be the top for you so they're
indexed in time so I have one variable
for let's say we because CT can be a
discrete can be a subset of not integers
but whole numbers and can be an interval
of R so it's just points in time and I
have a variable for time one and tribal
for time two or if this minute and
probable for next minute and very
naturally we have going to have we don't
assume anything else besides that so I
can have an infinite family and for each
second from now on until the end of the
universe or until forever I can have a
different real random arrival so not
that not assuming much and when we talk
about time series data we assume them to
be sequence of real values taken
successfully equally spaced points in
time we can deal with non non equally
spaced points but we'll never do it here
there are ways to do it but they're not
usually almost always we talk about
equally spaced points and we think of
these series of values as either finit
or infinite realizations of the
sarcastic process meaning we went
through two real random variables we
have indexed in time and we sampled from
each of them a single arrival so what we
have to think about is that when we fake
about Kree ality or the values we see in
time series data we think of them just
as just a single realization the only
one we've ever seen of this mysterious
series of random variables that we don't
have any access to and if we have in a
sense I think about like sea
temperatures we
just this one serious like temperature
is all over the world or the single
ocean we don't have this phenomenon
happening anywhere else it's not
temperatures of a thermometer in
different places well do we have this
one series this is only single
realization ever in history of this
random variable so it's I gotta say it's
not a very optimistic start to because
we kind of like thinking
probabilistically every second in time
is different at the moment right each
one of them has a different kind of
arrival what an important another
important term to know is lag so a ledge
of a time series is just the same time
series back shifted by I so we call back
shaped by I climb steps the I flag all
the time series people also sometimes
called the lag of a specific point the
point that is shipped back shifted by by
K or Han or I backwards but usually when
we say illegal we mean the leg of the
series not a specific time point and it
has it defines an operator over time
series to just if you apply the leg
operator once over time series it back
shifts it once and if you apply it
powers of it I times you back shifted PI
times so this is the notation I don't
think it I don't think it comes out
maybe comes up once in the lecture but
it does comes up comes up a lot in
causal inference on time series data and
legs are a really big part of causal
inference in terms of data and another
another major way we think about time
series data in the context of stochastic
processes or the simplest way to think
of it is to say well my stochastic
process now is way more simpler than
just the basic assumption of a sequence
of random variables that are super
they're not independent but I have no
idea how to related I'm gonna say every
every value in my series is generated by
a very specific equation it's very
explicit so you can see we have took one
common such a model is the auto
regressive model which has which says at
time T the value is generated by we have
some
constant here see and it's just a moving
average basically it's just an average
of the last P points that less P values
in the previous P time points of the
same series and we have some random
noise there absolutely which is usually
a Gaussian white noise process of course
on stochastic process and this is it
means that once I have the first value
in the series right or the less p values
I can go on and predict almost exactly
the time series just with an error of
just the error the right of the noise
process there and this can be
generalized for vectors of random
variables in a sense that now every we
think of X as a vector that comes from a
sequence of random variables so each
point in time have a sequence of random
variables with a specific length and now
all the instead of single number of
parameters we have matrices that govern
how would generate the director of
points in time T so we can just think of
them as a lot of either a lot of single
ones that stack another important one is
that moving average small which it's
just a moving average of the last P or Q
random shocks so we have we have a
random noise generated at each point and
then the value of the series is just the
noise of the current point plus some
kind of weighted average of the last Q
noise points generated and both of these
are really really simple right but it
turned to be kind of strong models for
stochastic processes and they can
usually the point is more than they they
catch everything they we can approximate
a lot of things if we started from these
models as building blocks and so they
kind of turn up especially in the
beginning of the history of
causal inference and and investigating
in modeling time series data but they do
make strong assumptions and as you as
we'll see as we move forward in time we
try to make assumptions that are not as
strong as this one on the way
stochastic processes are built and so
we'll move out of this kind of like kind
of silly looking models but they're
still kinda important you know ma and AR
you can combine them to get ARMA and if
you have a Rhema or relax their variants
of these models and they and they're
super they're still really really common
if you don't eat it directly I mean in a
lot of things dealing with time series
data they they kind of end and one of
the components inside of things so that
was stochastic processes and crash
course so back to causal inference the
if there is like the only thing you need
to remember from the notions from the
definition the basic history piece about
causal inferences Granger causality it's
the first definition for causality in
time series data it's the most important
one
even new notions of it kind of related
says we we are giving an alternative to
it we are very giving
we're doing a change it just for to
adapt it to some kind of problem it has
but it is it is the point of reference
for a lot of work in the field and it's
very very intuitive so it's like I think
it was defined in 58 or something so
it's very early in the in the field of
statistics and a lot and around I mean I
think it also might have been around
econometrics so the basic idea is we
have to stochastic processes X&Y and we
have all the information on the universe
so let's not ask how we have it well
that's assume we have it and the core
idea is if when I throw away X and I
kind of look at it and you can look at
you all the information the universal
Silex I can predict Y to a lesser degree
then X causes Y because X can it means X
contained
unique information about wife can it
contain nowhere else in the universe
agrees in a way like why is looking at X
determine its value if it's caused this
driven by X and thus X Granger causes Y
this is the basic idea so this is starts
off with a definition it's obviously
very impractical but it's everybody
everybody got a basic idea so we can see
that predictability comes right at the
start right so we said pretty cool thing
is not good enough what we have here
predictability it just have a very
strong addition need to condition on all
the other information in the universe
and then predictability is enough so we
have a bit more formal definition so we
have these sets of of stochastic
processes that all information in the
universe until time I and this is like
the random variables right these are not
time series later donor points and all
the information makes them till time I
and and now we build a model and predict
why I using you are the series of
stochastic of random variables until
time I and then we do the same given all
information vertices inside X I and we
look at the variance right of the
residual the error we have predicting Y
I using each of them and then we say
something very simple if we have less
error when we used X the time strangers
have arrived the sequence of arrivals
random variables then x squared root
causes Y and and if we have both we say
they have a feedback so this is the
formal definition right so so what this
thing doesn't state is how we predict it
right that given a model that predicts y
from a set of stochastic of a sequence
of rent of random variables we have we
have a prediction model we can have a
way to say if X cos x causes Y or not
Reggie causes whether or not it does
limit causality to a specific notion of
causality because all in the meaning
some definitions do vary in that but it
doesn't specify a prediction melody
sense it's very flexible but it is very
unrealistic so in usually what is done
in reality is between replace you with a
specific set of time series we can look
at implicitly what a lot of mental
methods don't say is that we assume
these are all the relevant information
and then we say X granger cause as well
with respect to bold X that all our
information all relevant information in
a sense and there's a big big assumption
and that underlies the whole field of :
Princeton time series data that whatever
set we take of all relevant information
if we take enough of it if we if we do
get all relevant information or enough
of it then the degree that causal
inference method is approximates the
real right causality detection rate or
they also the power the degree of causal
of causal connection to a good degree
and I would say maybe it's it's
something we all make and such a beyond
like without thinking I don't know if
it's a good assumption to assume if we
have 150 relevant stochastic processes
and we all we have realization 149 you
just assume that the degree of that the
inference we do for causal inference is
gonna be good enough that we do detect
causal links and it gonna be are we
gonna ask to mate the strap of them to a
good degree is I don't think it's
trivial because it really depends on the
relation between the one missing time
series of stochastic processes the one
you're looking at so it's always the
catch here is kind of this super strong
assumption I'm looking at all relevant
data and we'll see some ways some
methods very few that do try to tackle
this assumption a bit more hello and so
I kind of say that I just want to origin
you need to you just need to kind of get
the intuition behind the idea because it
will keep popping up and you see a lot
of things with a lot of metals with G in
their initials because it's for Granger
so they're like kinda
like free definitions for Coughlin's
present times use data before cutting
taxes they came after Granger causality
and we I don't think it's worth the time
going into them I just want to say a few
words
on each of them so since causality was
defining a paper by a guy named seems
like a few month or year or two after
Granger if I if I remember correctly and
it was thought to be equivalent it was
more of a paper that kind of like looked
at credit causality and kind of added
some information about it turned out to
be an equivalent in in some cases and it
turned out Granger is a stronger
definition so when you look at the paper
it's kinda hard to understand but just
just just know that if you're ever
looking at things that say they use sink
Simms causality just know it's not the
same as causality it's not a different
name for it turns out in specific
circumstances it's different another
definition which is kind of natural to
think about goes its called structural
causality looks at the structure of the
time of the stochastic processes how
they define it looks at the GDP data
data generation process and says okay
we'll think of both x and y as functions
of the past of each of them and and all
and all other relevant observed
variables and also all unobserved
variables so a lot of still it still has
all this all information in the universe
thing and we say that X doesn't cause by
the way all the definitions even the
gradual ones define what doesn't cause
and then we say if we don't find it and
say it's X cos Y so X doesn't cause Y if
the function that defines how Y
progresses is constant in values of the
past of X for all are admissible values
of all the rest of the series which is
the kind of like the functional
equivalent for mathematical functions
over the map for saying that right
it doesn't help predicting power so
which kind of in which case X wouldn't
help
to predict why if a little think of FY
is a function of X when it's constant in
values of X right and the last one is
intervention causality so it's kind of
like another very intuitive way to think
about Co Sahari and it says given two
processes x and y let's assume you can
intervene in X again a very strong
assumption so this is really valid in
some cases perform intervention in X and
observe Y and then measure the
differences in Y between no intervention
matter into an intervention and if we
assume the expected value of y y am you
can always play around values together
it's expected I'll just measure the
expected value out of the of the series
under the intervention they define all
types of intervention and the
interesting point about intervention
causalities is that they really try to
do based on this kind of idea how to
model causality in a different way even
from cases that you can't perform
interventions but it is I haven't seen
it really used anywhere so it's more
theoretically interesting so the key
takeaway from here is remember gradient
causality which says edit predictability
given a lot of data
just remember this term so let's let's
start going over about how you can infer
causal links between two times your data
or more and we'll start the the start
usually begins it at two times its data
so we're like the set of things will go
over let's start with the most the
classical methods are gonna be both kind
of turned out to be not good enough at
all so here's the first one it's really
really bad and that says we want to
check if time-series X causes Y so it's
very intuitive right let's generate a
lot of legs of X let's make sure that
once twice three times etc we'll decide
later how many legs parentheses
can it's a model it's a model it's a
model criteria its information it can be
solved information criteria methods how
how many legs to generate and then for
each of those legs
check the correlation of the new time
series with the unlit version of y and
if the correlation is high then you can
say X causes Y but this is very
intuitive right if I if I assume X
causes Y it kind of it drives something
and Y but I'm assuming there's some kind
of like a time delay between the cause
and the effect so if I back shift X I'm
going to see I'm gonna kind of like see
them overlay over each other in very
intuitive sense so this turns out to
work really bad it's super sensitive
test seasonality it's super insensitive
to confounders which it means driving
variables that affect both both series
this is the reason why we the saying
causality doesn't correlation doesn't
imply causality is exist and it was
shown to produce a lot of missing
inclusions nobody uses it basically it's
used in client research sometimes like
basically a lot of the things we'll see
even if they start out from this bad
from the starting point to add a lot of
things after it to to make it better
a second approach is it says ok let's do
something else let's use our tools for
mulling stochastic processes and let's
try I have two models the first will be
the restricted model we'll just say this
is we and you can see here is the
average order vector autoregressive
model with y is defined by some kind of
a weighted average of its last p-values
and some kind of random noise and the
unrestricted model will say Y is
generated by a weighted average of its
last P values but also the last T values
of X so we have a very specific linear
way in which X affects Y and now we have
we can we can state analysis it says all
these parameters bad beta the
coefficients of X in the interaction
model are zero
and now we can we have we can check this
we can use one very statistical test
developed for this to check the not help
office and you can see there were a lot
of things you might have heard the names
of from general generally 56 I do
mention here a specific method or
procedure that handles a lot of specific
phenomenon times your data is imported a
total emotive procedure so it makes a
lot of strong assumptions assumes the
link is linear as soon as the that
linear order aggressive models are good
models of the time series data we look
at this turned out more and more to be
not good enough for modeling time series
data and so a lot of modern research
adds things over auto regressive models
or uses way more sophisticated models or
just uses a nonparametric ways of two
more times your data over to analyze it
but if you are sure that linear is good
enough that type of causal link and the
model of the times use of the stochastic
process then by all means to go ahead
and use one of these classical methods
if you do then the please use the the
turning on water procedures because it's
a very late one and it kind of like a
modern variation a lot of these that
treats a lot of problems in the early
ones and and so what is funny when you
look at it when you look at the economic
ricky'll research literature over the
years you can see a lot of people every
one of them coming up with a different
approach to test this and then they all
arrive at super different conclusions
about the effects of different stock
prices on on currency prices or trading
volumes because because this is really
not a good enough model so they just
keep publishing papers and say this is
this affects this assuming and then just
like this very long list of not of too
strong assumptions will cave a
parametric methods so there are maybe
I'll skip ahead for a couple of
interesting ones so there are a lot of
other interesting parametric matters you
can throw in different modes to predict
right like multi-layer perceptrons you
can people do
works all kind of stuff but I want to
show you really a cool one and a few
minutes I have left and it's a chaos
theory one based on chaos theory so this
is the picture I chose to go to showcase
ok so it really it's a field of research
that to call in 70s and early 80's and
and it had a at least one important
application of statistics it says
actually the terminus stick processes
can look random and might be extremely
hard to predict it's the thing we didn't
think about deterministic process it can
be really dependent on starting
conditions and and this was a this is an
example of a very simple heuristic
function that has the same
autocorrelation function as a very
famous second-order white noise process
which is like the building block of
stochastic processes this is a problem
because white noise bonuses are like the
base the base in the basic building
block of stochastic process modeling and
now we have this thing that looks like a
Vitamix process and it's basically a
deterministic process and it doesn't
have any of the properties we're talking
about and and so the response and in a
way to this specific problem is develop
a set of statistical tests that can
determine whether a specific model like
the one we saw here so this is also a
more modern right kind of simple auto
regressive model is it a deterministic
chaos process or is it really stochastic
and so we turned out that in this where
we got a nonlinear test for general
causality so it is a deterrent to not
check Granger so it has a very a
variation of it but it's very important
to look at and at the cooler example as
from the field that deals with dynamical
system so let's assume form and we have
this kind of dynamical system like all
the systems we're talking about like the
relation between daily stock prices and
daily trading volumes and we have these
two may be very simple deterministic
equations determining the the dynamic
between them
but it it's it's a chaotic system which
means it might be very hard to predict
but look almost random and we have kind
of a single sensor sampling it it
generates a time series this is exactly
what we have when we look at like a
creating volume price so even we have
this like it's ghost is called an
manifold this describes the way the
process moves for space in time so we
have this like three kind of related
processes like daily trading volume
daily stock prices and I don't know sea
temperatures and this dictates how they
affect each other and is they kind of
move around the state space just the act
of doing this project the hub the state
space into a single axis and now we when
basically what we're trying to do what
chaos theory in dynamic system tells us
is when we study these kind of processes
from a formulas flight time series are
cracked inflate the state space back
from a very flat line and so how can we
in fact it back so derivatives turned
out to be really bad because they kind
of magnify noise because the way they
are calculated because the way they are
defined
there's a good example of the way this
is like the state space that using
derivatives will say a pendulum that
moves
I have a very simple state space it will
describe it of looking something like
this
[Music]
so the solution we have is called delay
coordinate coordinate embedding that's
really cool so the basic idea is plot
the data against the late versions of
its own well look at a very
one-dimensional example we have this
values of X versus the time of T now we
start to look at the late versions of T
and plot them together on this free
dimensional axis look at it intuitively
this makes no sense right so we have
here this we first point it takes the
value x 1 3 and 5 and we plot them on a
three-dimensional space then we move
this one step down and plot the values
of time 2 4 and 6 and we keep doing this
and this has two parameters how many
teeth will be taken our comm and the
spacing between them and we get this
weird manifold and pretty space for this
space so we seem like we have this state
space and we measure this one living and
then from a single measurement when we
do this this is done with I think a
delay of this is the delay right yeah
the spacing is of 150 we get back this
kind another manifold and the
interesting thing about it this is a
very famous theorem taken theorem it
says if we choose to write values for
the delay and enough dimensions the
manifold would get this kind of state
space to describe dynamic is the same in
a very specific way that is it is good
enough worse so now we have this
powerful tool we can use for causal
imprints this is the coolest message
that I wanted to show today converging
cross mapping so let's assume we have
this state space on the top BAM
so and we still assume x and y are
causally related so they're basically
the state variables of our dynamical
system they're the two things we have
the two questions describing the the
dynamics between them and there's a
caveat here you don't have to really
have this the exact state grounds so
let's do the use delayed coordinate
embedded embedding and get this what's
called a shadow manifold it's not the
original manifold for each of them we
download the generality right they
should produce the same state manifold
because they're causally related so now
we have we did we had X and we had Y two
time series and now we use each of them
to generate using the laid coordinate
embedding the very unintuitive thing of
plotting a figure gets a billion copies
of itself these two manifolds and
because they mapped one to want to the
original manifold that's what tak-tek
instill and tells us they also want to
want to each other and now what this
tells us that if
points are
by on Amex on the manifold that was
generated by M for my they'll be there
this group corresponds to point that
should also be nearby on Amex and now we
have a causal inference algorithm just
find a group of nearest neighbors in in
manifold my look at the corresponding
points on M X by the time and Isis right
and if they're also nearest neighbors if
they kind of satisfy criteria of nearest
neighbor some kind of Delta then x and y
are causally related and first of all
this is very cool you can show a lot of
cool gifts from this kind of methods and
the second thing is is it's
nonparametric right we did in a soon
model of the stochastic process at all
and this kind of nonparametric methods
tend to be super super strong and I do
suggest you always if you're not sure
about the way to model your process and
you're not sure about the assumptions
you can make do look at nonparametric
models so I'm gonna skip about things
during my information theory and graph
theory which is also very cool and it's
just gonna say a few words and then one
minute I have left about how to choose
which tools to use so first of all if
you wanna if you decide between using
classical Granger based methods make
sure your data does satisfy the
assumption of separable ax T that you
can that each type of like kind of
effect is separated in a different time
series this the assumption that gradual
makes and if you have if you kind of if
each time series is a mixture of the
real variables in a sense of the state
variables of the system's grandeur
causality is not gonna work so if you do
use the tools like CCM that converted
cross hopping I showed or PCM CI which
have either are nonparametric or have
nonparametric ways to use them like see
a PCMCIA is a graphics algorithm it's
always it's based on independence test
and if you use nonparametric
independence tests it it makes the whole
system not permit
if you use it when you test use the
newest one as I said if you're not sure
about how to model your system to use do
you use nonparametric - because mommy's
specification is I think the most common
method we want to try to model the world
and various sophisticated processes so
and you have nothing to guide you except
a domain knowledge and intuition when
you decide in this right nobody's gonna
tell you if your guy's gonna satisfy it
and the last thing is we didn't touch it
but system is our ability last met most
methods as soon you you can look at all
rent all relevant rivals so if you think
this assumption is not met look at
models that kind of model latent
variables which mean unseen variables
explicitly so one of these are is
presented in the presentation there's I
think one maybe one more out of 20
methods they looked at at blog post and
this is a blog post and this was the
talk right now it's questions sample
questions yes so I if he has a specific
algorithm for causal inference in time
series data is different from the ones
shown here like maybe I'm not it's
basically different from graduate
causality then dude I I'd love to look
at it for my I look at the person work
was most mostly on causal inference um
on nine times you Tony solution so I
just don't know the methods it hasn't
everything it's definitely not sure and
depend over the great you algorithm that
Rosa
doesn't assume you know the very cool so
I'll definitely look it I didn't I tried
to look at it and edit where I should
because I am I ready I'm of pearls
finger but I didn't ran into the time
serious one
I don't yeah so the question was whether
like causal inference is not in the time
over time domain frequency domain and my
answer is I have no idea I really never
worked I think with frequency theta so I
wouldn't be the person to ask yeah one
more I'm stealing the time so and the
question was about missing data in the
time series itself so I said most models
you don't treat it I think you'll have
to try to extrapolate it it's gonna get
you into the parametric model bind
because you're gonna have a decided a
model of your specific of your dynamic
process but my my intuition on the spot
is that you kind of like have no other
way maybe look at nonparametric ways to
accept idea but I can think of a
nonparametric way to to add data into
missing points but and then you can
start with these that assume you have
all the data thank you very much no more
time for me
[Applause]